the future shamans among the Tungus as
they approach maturity go through a
hysterical or a history crisis but
sometimes their vocation manifests
itself at an earlier age the boy runs
away into the mountains and remains
there for a week or more feeding on
animals which he tears to pieces with
his teeth he returns to the village
filthy blood-stained and it's only after
ten or more days that have passed that
he begins to babble incoherent words the
strange behavior of future shamans has
not failed to attract the attention of
scholars and from the middle of the past
century several attempts have been made
to explain the phenomena as a mental
disorder but the problem was wrongly put
from the one hand it is not true that
shamans always are or always have to be
neuropathic in mentally deranged on the
other hand and this is the critical
issue those among them who would be Neel
become shamans precisely because they
had succeeded in becoming cured so it
was it's not the descent into this
strange subterranean psychological state
that constitutes the transformation that
makes the shaman but it's the emergence
back out of that and that's a journey to
the underworld in a and a rebirth right
and so and there's this great book this
is a great book my guy named Henry Ellen
birch a and he was an existential
psychoanalyst and philosopher and he
wrote a book called the discovery of the
unconscious which I would highly
recommend it's on my list of recommended
readings it is a great book if you want
to know about the psychoanalytic
tradition it's the best introduction
there is and he discusses Adler and Jung
and Freud and there's a very credible
job of all three but also takes the
history of psychoanalytic thought back
three or four hundred years before Freud
and so it's it's very engaging reading
and and and very interesting and one of
the things alan burridge a points out
quite clearly is and he associates this
to some degree with this shamanic
tradition that both Freud and Jung Jung
in particular underwent very intense
periods of psychological disturbance
let's say and I would say what was
happening is that because they were
questioning their axioms at the most
fundamental level they were deranging
their cognitive and perceptual
structures right and Jung was also
experimenting with imaginative
techniques with visionary techniques
which he which
did a lot and there is a period of his
life where he was having constant a
constant stream of visions which he
wrote down in a book called the red book
but at the same time he was still
functioning as a psychiatrist and
operating normally in the world and so
you know people have suggested that what
he had was a psychotic break but that's
ridiculous because you don't know that's
not how it works man if you're having a
psychotic break you you know I've been
an effective psychiatrist those things
do not go together especially not for a
long period of time and so there there's
the possibility of extreme experience
without psychosis psychopathology and so
and elenberg says much the same thing
about Freud and about Charles Darwin as
well who underwent a terrible period of
of mental confusion I would say as a
consequence of formulating his theory of
evolution which was really hard on him
because he was a he was a die-hard
Christian and he knew what he knew what
the implications of his theory word he
didn't know what to do about that you
know so it was very very hard on him so
it's quite common for people of genius
to go through an intense crisis
psychological crisis but then resolve it
and the genius is in the resolution
right the precondition for the genius is
the dissolution in some sense because
you have to be obsessed with the problem
it has to grip you completely before
you're going to concentrate it on its so
obsessively that you might come up with
a solution but it's the people who come
up with a solution that are the prophets
in the shaman and so forth and so on and
and and so that's not this isn't
something that only characterizes our
cultures we just don't recognize it in
our own culture properly and and that's
a problem well sometimes we do right you
remember that in the Lion King right
that prophy key shows up he's the shaman
he brings he brings a Simba down that
tunnel dark tunnel that's the dark night
of the soul he hasn't reflected upon
himself in a pool when he reflects upon
himself deeply he sees the reflection of
his father then that becomes a car thing
of cosmic significance and his father
appears in the sky just like God appears
to jacob and basically tells him that
it's time for him to grow the hell up
and to return to the devastated Kingdom
and to set it right you know and so and
that's right that's exactly right I mean
we live in the devastated Kingdom that's
an eternal truth and it's the
responsibility of the individual to grow
the hell up
and to set it right because when it's
devastated and when things are not in
place then everyone suffers too much and
that's not good and there's no excuse
for not doing something about it because
you don't have anything better to do
so and even like children's movies tell
you this